I'm sure if someone were to look inside
my window while I'm playing they
probably would have no idea what's going
on in here to watch a theremin being
played looks really strange my name is
Pamela and Stickney and one of the
instruments I'd love to play is a Sarah
Minh like what the hell was that I don't
know so the salmon is a synthesizer and
it's a synthesizer that's not controlled
with the use of a keyboard like a piano
I'm controlling the pitches with my left
hand and this hand is just the
articulation hands the volume
it's controlled without any physical
contact and you can make it like a bird
the really big challenge with the
instrument is its reacting not just to
my hands and how they're moving in my
fingers it's sensitive as well into my
whole body I've recorded on an album of
David Burns Grace Jones the Indigo Girls
it's such a new instrument still that
there's nobody who's going to stand
there and say you're not doing it the
way it's supposed to be done I don't
think there's anything else like it it
doesn't relate to anything else I've
ever played
you